[Applause]
thank you
I'm running to serve Pennsylvania
Mamma Mia sometimes the world has a way
of showing you something without even
having to say it uh I'm Dave Rubin this
is the Reuben report it is November 7th
Monday November 7th 2022 and if you've
been hiding under a rock tomorrow is
election day and there is an awful lot
to talk about because the Dems and the
media and big text throwing in the
kitchen sink but I really believe enough
people have finally woken up I think
tomorrow is going to be a very very good
day it's going to be a particularly good
day here in the Free State of Florida
but I think it's going to be a really
good day for America I think we can
reverse some of this craziness the slow
descent to hell that I'm often talking
about I think we can actually get past
it I think we can start restoring in
America that we got close to giving away
and as I owe say people you don't have
to be a republican but you cannot be a
Democrat especially right now so
regardless is if over the course of the
next 45 minutes or so you agree with
everything I say or you disagree with
everything I say or you like a little
bit you don't like a little bit of
whatever it is just get out there and
vote participate in the process because
that's what it's all about you know if
you if you don't vote if you don't get
out there if you don't have your voice
heard and then you just complain all day
well then you probably get what you
deserve so uh we are going to be
recapping a little of uh what this last
year uh what how this how we got here
basically uh with some interviews I've
done in the past uh just some of the
people that became rock stars in the
midst of all of this some of the people
that became hysterical lunatics uh and
much more and then tomorrow because I
didn't want to early vote I wanted to
vote on Election Day uh my guys have to
vote at a different uh location than I
do but then we're all going to meet
together at my location we're going to
try to shoot something there maybe live
stream I know there's some uh
restrictions on where you can actually
shoot things and whatever else but we
will do that tomorrow and then we will
do the live show normal as always 11
o'clock Eastern right here and then we
are hopping in the car and we are
driving cross state to Tampa where
tomorrow night uh I and Lisa Booth will
be co-hosting the DeSantis Victory party
at the Tampa Convention Center so we're
co-hosting Matt thing and yes it's going
to be a victory party I'm not worried
about that and we will do a live show
from the venue hopefully we'll get to
chat with the governor and there'll be a
bunch of other special guests and all
that good stuff so it's going to be a
busy day I'm psyched and ready to roll
and before we get to anything else let
me talk to you guys about comicoto
knives you know it's time to up your
kitchen knife game with kamikoto knives
using traditional techniques kamikono
crafts beautiful knives using steel
Source from Japan each blade is made
with techniques that have been owned and
perfected by generations of knife Smiths
they come in a beautiful heavy duty Ash
wood box and every blade is individually
inspected and comes with a lifetime
guarantee because of their single bevel
Edge kamikoto knives can achieve a
wickedly sharp edge the kind you just
can't get with other knives these are
cut through your rib eye like butter
sharp kamikoto knives are used by
several chefs working at Michelin star
restaurants around the world they make
amazing gifts that come in beautiful
boxes you can maintain each knife's edge
with one of Tommy koto's sharpening wet
stones and like I said they're so
confident in their product that each
knife comes with a lifetime guarantee if
you go ahead and buy now kamikodo's
offering you an extra fifty dollars off
site wide on top of their Black Friday
sale which will kick in uh on Black
Friday just a couple weeks go to
kamikodo.com Reuben and use the offer
code Reuben for an extra fifty dollars
off
kamikoto.com Reuben
k-a-m-i-k-o-t-o.com slash Reuben all
right so let's get to it it looks like a
Red Wave is it coming it should be a
coming I think there's every reason to
vote for Republicans there's almost no
reason to vote for Democrats I mean
unless you're into chopping kids
genitals off and causing crazy inflation
and crime on the streets and releasing
criminals and pushing Grandma into the
subway and all that if you're into all
that then vote Democrat if you're not
then you pretty much have to vote
Republican and will Republicans probably
fail us
over the course of the next couple years
yes most likely most of them will not
all of them there are a couple good ones
but they'll probably not do everything
we want them to do but the point is most
people most sane decent moderate people
have realized the woke thing has just
got to go and one of the guys who I've
been working on for a couple years as
you know is Bill Maher and he now even
understands the Red Wave is a common I
am very much a critique a Critic of uh
what goes on On The Fringe of the left I
mean woke culture has just that's one
reason why the Republicans are going to
do so well in this election because the
left has gone super crazy with lots of
[ __ ] that the average American just
never voted for doesn't recognize in
this country doesn't want and pay
attention to and doesn't Okay so I don't
want to belabor the point with Bill you
guys get it already the the real issue
is that the left had a chance to listen
to a guy like Bill instead of try to
destroy a guy like Bill but as I said
when I sat down with him just a couple
weeks ago on the club brandom podcast
it's like you know he could show up to a
republican rally to a trump Rally or he
could show up to an event that I did
like a comedy show or whatever it might
be or anything right-leaning and most
people would dig him they would be like
oh there's Bill Maher that's cool he's
coming around he's kind of saying upload
him and a few but sure a few people
might Heckle him or a couple people
might be like he's part of the problem
okay fine but he could clearly go there
and and be respected and listen to
certainly people would listen to him and
not shout him down now try the other
side of it and Bill fully admitted this
in our chat if Bill was to go to a
progressive rally say an AOC rally right
what would happen to him he would be
shouted down he would probably be
violently attacked or pushed out or
silenced or whatever it might be so
unfortunately the left did not listen to
the Dave rubins of years ago they did
not listen to the bill Mars they didn't
listen to the Joe Rogan's they didn't
listen to any of the people that were
going guys enough is enough of this we
are not acting liberally uh can we fix
this thing can we turn this thing around
any of it they didn't listen to any of
it and they went completely crazy uh now
you may remember also a couple weeks ago
we've played this a couple times I think
it's worth playing one more time for now
and then we'll probably put it down for
the rest of the year because I think
tomorrow is going to go well uh you may
remember when I sat down with Bill uh he
we he still seemed to not really connect
what was going on with Trump and why
people voted for Trump and and that
things really aren't working now and
that you got to stop voting for the
people who are ushering in all the
madness first of all you got to break up
with your boyfriend Donald Trump who
would you say is more authentic him or
Joe Biden
him he's more authentic him or Elizabeth
Warren but authentic does it mean good
if you're authentically a crazy person
pretty good when he was president what
what was pretty good we weren't in a
recession the Border was a little bit
better we didn't have a crazy war in
Ukraine like there were things come on
you have to admit he hasn't conceded the
election for four years when he was
president Hillary Clinton he's an
illegitimate president he didn't say
that yes she did I met him and I I kind
of was like all right he's not evil he's
not Hitler and he's certainly not a
homophobe I used to have these Trump
rallies on Sundays and I was like you
know what I'm gonna go and just see what
it's like there were American flags
everywhere there were gays for Trump
Latinos for Trump really yes everywhere
and nobody cared and by the way they
didn't burn down Rodeo Drive like black
lives matter and I'm telling you you
could have walked in that audience and
people would have yes would a certain
amount of people have been like I [ __ ]
Bill Maher and but but you know what a
lot of people would have been there like
you know what Bill Maher's here that's
pretty cool think how different that
would be than if you went to an AOC
rally where you would be hated Beyond
imagination you're right I don't mean
that as I know it's like it's just true
it's just they're they're more the left
or more purists all right so the reason
I'm showing you that one more time is
because this is where the country's at
the people who I think tomorrow are
really going to decide the election are
going to be the sort of former Dave
Rubin types the the current Bill Maher
types the the Liberals mugged by reality
because we know that a certain amount of
people always vote Republican a certain
amount of people always vote Democrat so
when you when you're having an election
it's really about whatever that
percentage of people that actually could
move is it's probably only about 10
percent of people that actually could
move I think in this midterm it's more
than 10 because so many people for the
two years of covid lockdowns and all the
craziness and all of the people that
have moved all over the country that use
their foot vote and got out of the
dystopian cities and moved to places of
freedom I think more people than usual
in this particular election get it right
like there's obviously something very
special about this election I I wish it
was just a regular nonsensical election
but this one is actually special because
is because freedom is truly on the
docket right like that's what people are
really voting for this time they are not
voting because they like or dislike
Trump they're voting because they've had
had it when it comes to whether they can
go to work or leave their house or what
they're doing to your kids and the
Litany of other issues you get that so
this is not really about Trump well
certainly not about Trump it's not even
about Biden really it's about freedom
freedom is what you were voting for and
for some reason the Democrats have
convinced a lot of people that the party
that is more for Freedom obviously the
Republican party is also the fascist
party it makes no sense but
you got to give the devil is due these
people when you control the media and
you control a big Tech and you control
the narrative you can get a lot of
people to believe a lot of wrong things
anyway related to Joe Biden because it
does have a little something to do with
him he's the incumbent president and we
know that the incumbent president's
party pretty much always does horribly
in midterms uh well Joe Biden's uh
approval ratings are at an all-time low
of 28 percent 81 million people voted
for him 28 here's msnbc's Chuck Todd
Biden's job approval rating sits at 44
in this final NBC News poll by the way
all-time low with Independence his
approval rating is just 28 okay sorry
sorry I should clarify that so it was 28
with Independence now again those
Independents those are the people that
sometimes go this way sometimes goes
sometimes go this way so that's what's
so interesting about this the people who
can move right now they've clearly had
it with the Democrats and again you just
have to think about what did people
actually do this in the in the last two
years people that that were frustrated
they left blue States and blue cities
they didn't nobody left Texas really
right nobody left Florida nobody left
Tennessee but blue generally blue people
did move to Red places and that tells
you something about a trend and that
trend is now in these last few days when
CNN and MSNBC and all all these other
places when they could have been
reporting on what was happening honestly
when they could have been telling their
people for years what was really going
on here and stop making it seem like
Republicans are all racist and Democrats
are all automatically good guys but they
didn't do that but now they're seeing
the polls they're seeing the trends and
it is too hard to ignore so what's
happening on CNN well even Democrat
activists are showing up on CNN and
saying man this is this is absolutely on
us this is Hillary Rosen who has been a
Democrat strategist for a couple decades
I think she worked for Hillary Clinton
if I'm not mistaken she's a Democrat
strategist and just listened to the Way
She lays it out to this panel Hillary
you have a different take maybe than
bakari on Democrats yeah I'm
I'm a loyal Democrat but I am not happy
I just think that we are you know we did
not listen to voters in this election
and I think we're gonna have a bad night
and you know this conversation is not
going to have much impact on Tuesday but
I hope it has an impact going forward
because when voters tell you over and
over and over again that they care
mostly about the economy
listen to them
all right so it's not easy for a
Democrat strategist to get up on CNN and
say we really screwed the pooch on this
thing now I don't know what makes
someone like Hillary and I've
interviewed her before I think many many
years ago I don't know what would make
someone like her at this point in 2022
say I'm a loyal Democrat like I just
don't know what's left there that's sort
of like the Bill Maher thing but okay
putting that aside she's acknowledging
hey people actually just cared about the
economy and crime those are pretty much
the big two right now and Democrats
instead of focusing on that well
actually they kind of focused on it and
made both those things worse right
defund the police inflation reduction
act blah blah blah they were also
focused on chopping kids genitals off
they were also focused on neo-racism
they were also focused on destroying our
history and tearing down statues and
everything else so the Democrats no
they're in for an ass a woman that's
what they're in for and there's many
reasons for it we're going to lay out a
whole bunch of them but guys as you know
tomorrow is the election and the blaze
wants to hook you up with some info
election night is tomorrow and the
stakes have never been higher for the
midterms a bunch of races across the
country have gotten very interesting in
the past couple weeks will Republicans
be able to win a senate seat in
Washington state is Kathy hochel really
in trouble in New York yes will voters
punish Gretchen Whitmer for her coveted
lockdown insanity and finally give her
the boot there's a ton to cover this
election cycle and the blaze has got you
covered head on over to theblaze.com
election guide to receive a free copy of
Blaze media's Ultimate Guide to the
midterms delivered straight to your
inbox that's theblaze.com election guide
and we'll send you everything you need
to know to be ready for the big election
night so okay
let's not forget what the Democrats did
to get us to this point because I know a
bunch of you watching this are probably
traditional Republicans and
conservatives but I also know a whole
bunch of you
are kind of Republican curious a whole
bunch of you are liberals who were
mugged a whole bunch of you are new to
this you're still going can I actually
pull the the lever can I press the
button for a republican tomorrow well
you just have to think about the last
couple years and then I think your
choice is pretty freaking clear here's
uh GOP chairwoman Rana McDonald uh
McDaniel sorry on CNN basically laying
out what the Democrats have done
an election yeah for the president
United States to give a speech and not
talk about inflation to actually say
it's good to not talk about gas prices
to say the crisis I'm not here they have
become crime deniers inflation I'm not
here okay and education is funny Dana
Bash is like I'm not here to defend the
Democrats but we know what you're there
for Dana like yeah yeah you are but the
point is the Democrats their their eye
is just not on the ball even in the last
couple days Biden still we're not going
to drill anymore like it's just
completely ridiculous uh here's some
video more from CNN people know what
reality is despite the fact that the
mainstream media doesn't want to show it
they go to the grocery store the bills
bills are higher gas the gas price the
gas tank train gets the gas station gets
way too much attention I think because a
lot of people you know hybrid commuting
fewer commutes like people feel lousy
about the economy 75 of people we pulled
say we're already in a recession
we are in a recession a recession has
always been defined as two consecutive
quarters of flattening of the GDP gross
domestic product we're in it right now
everyone knows we're in it and then
magically when it happened they suddenly
started redefining what a recession is
now I have to show you something from
MSNBC do we have a warning can we put up
a warning because this one of all of the
stupid things and racist things that Joy
Reid says and she says an extraordinary
amount of stupid and racist things and
often stupid raises things
um this one if you just listen to the
pandering nonsense that I cannot believe
anyone watches this that's my lead into
this clip how does p how do people watch
this crap
the people I ever heard you here use the
word inflation are journalists
um and economists right so that is not
part of the normal lexicon of the way
people talk so it's interesting that
Republicans are doing something they
don't normally do right which is not
used com the common tongue right not
used just common English to sort of use
do on their campaigns like they're doing
with prime but what they've done is
they've taught people the word inflation
right
inflation the word inflation is not part
of the common tongue I'm so fancy I'm so
I'm like right out of Downton Abbey over
here with all my fancy words oh my God
it's The King's English over here with
the word inflation lady everyone knows
what inflation is it's your party that
has destroyed this you destroy this
economy you have ushered this in and and
you see what she's trying to do there is
that it's not really that there's a
problem with the economy it's just that
the Republicans use fancy words to
describe things and
ah but fortunately nobody is buying any
of this anymore uh here's a video of of
a woman that I prayed to God by the end
of tomorrow night we can call former New
York Governor Kathy hochul just getting
crushed on what's going on in New York
with the crime
interrupt you then here's the problem we
don't feel safe you might be working
closely with mayor Adams you may have
spent a whole lot of money but I walk
into my Pharmacy and everything is on
lockdown because of shoplifters I'm not
going in the subway people don't feel
safe in this town so you may have done
these things but right now we're not
feeling good we're worried we could be
San Francisco we'll never be San
Francisco why because we are already
making a difference we already have
homicides and shootings down
dramatically
dramatically from what they had been
last year
lady you were in charge last year too
and if you want to parse it your guy
Andrew Cuomo was in charge a little bit
before that nobody buys any of this
anymore and the fact that MSNBC again
they're doing it two days before their
the election because they're covering
their butts they ushered in all of this
the mainstream media covered for the
Democrats they applauded as Democrat
antifa and BLM people burned down cities
and destroyed Pep Boys and Target and
all that you got it and now in the last
moments as they realize what's about to
happen now they have to cover their own
butts so they don't look like complete
sellouts and speaking of complete
sellouts here's msnbc's Joe Scarborough
who sort of at one time I guess
pretended to kind of be a Republican or
something but he's obviously a Democrat
he lies about virtually everything we've
played many clips of him taking every
position on everything depending on
who's in power but now he's even waking
up and realizing that yeah maybe you
don't want dudes beating chicks in
women's sports now let me offend a lot
of people yeah because that's what I do
how many progressives or how many
liberals will say things privately or
quietly let's take the the pin swimmer
the transitioned and they said now do
you really do you really I just
I don't think young women should have to
compete against somebody who
transitioned 82 percent of Americans
don't believe that men who transition
uh post puberty should be able to
compete against women in sports
yeah congratulations buddy it's your
party that has been ushering all of this
stuff in but again you get it it's a day
or two before the election so now you
realize that you better start sounding
sane because you gotta try to have a gig
right after right so what have we
covered here well we covered uh the The
Joy read inflation economy situation
right and you know apparently uh the
economy it's not a problem until
Republicans you started using these
fancy words like inflation I mean just
bananas uh crime and hochul well
everyone knows New York is is just in
the midst of a crazy crime wave uh
here's Joe Scarborough finally coming
around on the trans thing uh what else
do we have well we've got uh well
Joe Biden remember he was going to be a
Healer that was his big thing he was
going to heal us but then he decided to
do this kind of stuff
Donald Trump and the Niger Republicans
represented extremism that threatens the
very foundations of our Republic
I see okay well Mr I'm gonna respect you
and restore Civility and all of those
things no he kind of did that instead
but it's not just the rhetoric right
what else did he actually do well one of
the things that he did over the course
of these last two years he and his party
decided to have vaccine mandates and
force lockdowns and push kids out of
schools and put you in masks and all of
those things and they were going to
scare the hell out of you the entire
time and they were going to use the
levers of the government to control how
you live how do I know all this well
it's all on videotape
this is a pandemic of the unvaccinated
this is not about Freedom or personal
choice
it's about protecting yourself and those
around you
I'm announcing that the Department of
Labor
is developing an emergency rule
to require all employers with 100 or
more employees
that together employ over 80 million
workers
to ensure their workforces
are fully vaccinated for unvaccinated we
are looking at a winner of severe
illness and death for unvaccinated
that's on you Dems that is on you and
that man is an embarrassment and a
buffoon doesn't it now now that we're
too you know we're out of this thing and
everyone kind of realizes it was all
[ __ ] and everything else when you
when you watch that like think how
awfully authoritarian and hysterical
that was not just the the winter of
death that never came uh but this this
idea that that because you work because
you get some money in exchange for your
services from a company that they were
allowed to force you that that's what
that what he wanted he and his
government wanted they were allowed to
force you to inject yourself with things
and people have had it and again the
proof's in the pudding because where are
people moving they're moving from Blue
states to Red States okay that's what's
happening nobody's going the other way
so now that people are realizing this
and as I said as we get to these last
couple days before the election suddenly
the Democrats and MSNBC they're kind of
covering their butts and oh maybe we
shouldn't have been screaming about all
the trans stuff and the race stuff and
maybe we should have focused on the
economy because they they're real
realizing man it's bad and you guys did
all this you didn't have to do it you
did not have to do it if you would have
turned around when a guy like me three
four five years ago was screaming about
this stuff you would have a whole bunch
of people that were old school liberals
still in the Democrat Party but you
don't have them anymore you don't have
them they have left the train has left
the station so what do they want now as
they realize they're about to get
smashed now they want a truce we covered
this a couple days ago you may remember
this piece in the Atlantic it went
completely viral for all the wrong
reasons uh it was called let's declare a
pandemic amnesty and people were going
crazy about this because the same people
who want amnesty now listen to some of
the things that people in the Atlantic
were writing over the last couple years
the anti-vaccine right brought human
sacrifice to America
unvaccinated people need to Bear the
burden vaccine refusers don't get to
dictate terms anymore
some Americans no longer believe in the
common good
so that's where we're at you guys get it
they want forgiveness now
but I don't think we're at forgiveness
part yet we're at we gotta Crush you in
the elections tomorrow and then you guys
have to honestly come crawling back and
and we have to figure out what to do
with the fauces and wolenskies and all
of the people who got us into the into
this madness we have I don't know what
you do with them I don't know if it's
about public trials I don't like all
these public trials because it's just
endless distractions from reality and
everything else but no no no no no no
you don't get to declare amnesty because
you were awful for two years the people
who wanted to be left alone we weren't
awful you might have thought we were
wrong I mean this is the ultimate irony
in the whole thing when when kovid was
at the peak of covid and they were
locking everybody down and injecting
everybody and firing nurses and all that
stuff the worst that you could say uh if
you were honest and I get it most people
aren't honest but the worst you could
say about people like me people who
didn't want to get vaccinated or who
didn't want to force their friends and
employees to get vaccinated the worst
you could say about is if you were
honest would be boy those people don't
want to listen into us
right like that's it because you could
avoid us you didn't have to be around us
and if you believed as most people
believed at the time that the vaccine
worked it wouldn't have mattered whether
we were vaccinated or not okay but they
lied about everything what's the worst
we can say about them well you guys
tanked the economy you guys created a
situation where a generation of young
people are having speech defects and
having all sorts of weird socialization
problems you guys are the ones who who
pushed everyone to be online more and
now people are just weird and frightful
and bizarre and all of the stuff you
guys did all of this and what else did
you do you censored those of us who
didn't lose our minds the whole bunch of
us who kept fighting for Freedom who
wanted to ask questions and you're
allowed to do that in a free democracy
the ones who are a bit skeptical about
lockdowns and where the uh where coven
came from and all of that stuff uh well
you made sure that you used the power of
government and big Tech to silence us
and he even told us you even told us
that you were doing it so a couple of
the steps that we have
um you know that could be constructive
for the public health of the country are
uh providing uh for for Facebook or
other platforms to measure and publicly
share the impact of misinformation on
their platform and the audience it's
reaching uh also with the public with
all of you
um to create robust enforcement
strategies that bridge their properties
and provide transparency about rules you
shouldn't be banned from one platform
and not others if you for uh providing
misinformation out there taking faster
action against harmful posts
you want to know what fascism is guys
fascism is a representative of the
government saying that if you're banned
on one platform let's say you're banned
on Twitter that you should then be
banned across the board you should be
banned on Facebook Google YouTube blah
blah blah blah kind of like they did to
hey what was that guy's name Donald
Trump kind of like they did to Alex
Jones
etc etc they were the ones using
government power in coordination we now
know we know for a fact we covered it
last week but we knew it all along right
you remember the other video we could
have shown you but I've shown it to you
a thousand times of Saki saying we flag
posts for Facebook that's the government
coming in I had lawyer Ron Coleman on on
Friday uh talking about this
specifically it's not that the
government comes in with the with an
edict with a written order saying you
Facebook people Twitter people you
better censor this person they don't
write it all out and or go we're gonna
do this to you but when a government
person calls you think about you in your
own life I'll use an example of me if I
got a call from a federal agent a CIA
agent saying Dave we've been watching
your show we're a little concerned about
your misinformation could you just maybe
ease up on that kind of stuff or could
you cover things a little bit
differently or whatever well would that
be the government absolutely infringing
are they really stopping me or are they
saying hey we know what you're doing
it's a mafia tactic right that's what
they have done that is what they did
that's what people are now voting
against but the other thing that's
happening right now is because of this
Elon Musk Twitter situation uh more
speech seems to be getting out there
right there seems to because Twitter
whether you like Twitter or not or
whether it has ruined all of our brains
and the endless scrolling has destroyed
a whole bunch of people and the outrage
and all that whether you like it or not
Twitter still is the the pr wire the
public relations wire for the world that
is where the taste makers are and how
information is now disseminated in our
in our modern I suppose this is in the
modern world that we live in
so people are freaking out the same
people who were not upset when all sorts
of people were getting banned in silence
now they're upset that Elon Musk is
coming in he's not Banning or silencing
anybody he's just saying hey let's uh
let's just be a little more transparent
about our rules
um let's allow for more speech let's
figure out ways that we can do this a
little bit better without silencing
people so what's happening well the
system is crashing down on him from CNN
President Biden called out Elon Musk
saying the billionaire had purchased a
social media platform that spews lies
all across the world well of course Joe
Biden would know about lies because as
you remember in June of last year Joe
Biden if you get the coveted vaccine you
will not get nor transmit kovid uh Joe
Biden also told us that his inflation
reduction act would reduce inflation uh
Joe Biden also told us that last winter
was going to be a winter of severe death
Joe Biden also lied about Donald Trump
very fine people on both sides which is
the very reason that he launched his
campaign in the first place so when it
comes to misinformation come on dude
come on dude but what else have the
Democrats done well it is largely the
Democrats we certainly have a Democrat
Administration and mostly Democrats in
power who have led us into this very
bizarre War it's the war not war in
Afghanistan sorry in Ukraine because we
are well we had a disastrous withdrawal
from Afghanistan that everybody knows
about and now we have this war that we
haven't declared but we're funding to
the you know tune of billions and
billions of dollars in Ukraine uh which
also now is affecting Energy prices and
Western Europe has a huge huge problem
because of this nordstream pipeline
blowing up and Germany is going to have
all sorts of problems this winter
everybody knows about it but we've got
this bizarre war that nobody really
fully understands so what's going on
with the war in Ukraine right now well
uh TV shows that's what's happening take
a look at this
yeah that's uh
that's Vladimir zielinski Vlad zielinski
who was a comedian if you don't know
this he was a TV comedian who then
became a prime minister is he president
or he's president of Ukraine President
right uh president of Ukraine uh there
he is in Kiev sitting there in the
middle of this massive war and people
are telling us that there's a genocide
and all sorts of stuff he's there with
David Letterman and they're just hanging
out in the subway doing a show didn't
seem like anyone was too concerned that
they were going to get blown apart or
killed or murdered or have a Russian
bomb dropped on their head but that's
what's going on over there so the
theater portion of all of this okay you
guys get it so all right so then there's
the war and the energy what's the one
thing we haven't discussed that people
are also pissed about well there's the
Border situation and the Border
situation especially when it comes to
States like Texas and Arizona is going
to be absolutely massive when people go
to the voting booths tomorrow here is
Republican candidate Blake Masters
calling out Democrat incumbent senator
in Arizona Mark Kelly On the Border I've
been focused on the border since day one
on this job I'm down there all the time
I was on the phone this week just you
know with mayor Nichols of Yuma Sheriff
Daniels of Cochise County talking about
what more we need for border patrol and
immigration that my friends were called
Invasion we're working to raise border
patrol pay by 18 18 I've got legislation
to do that I've been focused on the
border since day one
okay yeah with no great effects because
we have a wide open Southern border so
if that's the best you can do I
respectfully request you resign and
let's get someone in the seat right who
will actually secure our border
so people have just had it right like if
you're the average person in Arizona and
Arizona is as purple estate as you can
get I think it's about to go very red
because of Blake and Carrie Lake
um but it's it's a purple state it goes
either way right we know it went for
Democrats last time the incumbent as I
just said markelli he's a Democrat but
people have just had it that you cannot
let people just wander into the country
and even if you can't blame Mark Kelly
for all of that I certainly think you
can blame him for some of it uh you have
to blame his party and the guy that's in
charge Joe Biden for what they've done
to our borders so now I want to go back
to a couple of the interviews that I've
done over the last year year and a half
because I I was warning about a lot of
this and I was also I think one of the
leaders in introducing you to some of
the candidates that was that we're gonna
fix some of this so I had Blake Masters
on originally in October of 2021.
basically nobody had heard of him he was
in a republican he had just gotten into
the Republican primary there were a
couple people that were way ahead of him
he had sort of no name recognition or
anything I was introduced to him through
Peter Thiel I thought he was just a good
dude he struck me as a good dude he was
the co-author of Peter thiel's book zero
to one which I think is one of the most
brilliant easily readable books if you
want to really think about the world a
little bit differently and how to really
change things but in any event I sat
down with Blake Masters this is a year
ago when I still lived in Crazy Cali to
ask why someone that's successful from
the tech world that doesn't need to get
into politics would be getting into
politics it's fair to say you even want
to go into politics in a way where
you're being sort of dragged to politics
I sense that with a lot of people that
are getting involved it was like I
didn't really want to be a politician at
first but somebody's got to fix this
somebody's going to head on somebody I
definitely have that that view of it
um I mean I'm getting into it I really
want to get into it I think it's
important but it'd be it'd be nice in
some sense like if I didn't have to like
if things were working if we didn't have
this establishment that uh that was
presiding over I think this cultural and
and uh economic Decay then I wouldn't
have to but that's not where we are and
I have to and I think we need some new
thinking in government so it's also the
most important thing I could be doing
left establishment and the right
establishment uh it doesn't work like
people you know he he it was the emperor
has no clothes on it
kind of right it's kind of right and
again this is a guy he's got cash
he's got a good boss well he stepped
down from his job with teal but the
point is he didn't have to get involved
he is he has a couple young kids
beautiful wife good life but people have
had it with all of this nonsense and
occasionally good people get involved I
would put Blake sort of at the top of
that list another person I would put on
that list is Tudor Dixon now Tudor Dixon
I did not know much about until about
two and a half weeks ago and then she
got into this debate with Gretchen
Whitmer and Gretchen Whitmer who of
course is the current governor of
Michigan who who is a liar who locked
everybody down who was one of the worst
who was partying for her husband's
birthday on a boat while she said other
people can't go out on boats and she
stopped people from gardening in their
backyards really awful stuff well then
Tudor Dixon got involved and Tudor Dixon
was just a mom I don't say just a mom
it's that's a little dismissive she was
a a mom of four young girls she saw what
the state was doing to her kids and she
got in the mix I interviewed heard this
past weekend this is this we just put
this up on Saturday it has about 350 000
views already because people are getting
it here's a little portion I think this
is the theme right now with this new
crop of politicians people that didn't
really want to be politicians this is
very interesting to see this the
Democrat Party kind of trying to they're
flailing they're trying to figure out
exactly who their base is and they seem
to have lost their base
so if you want to watch the full
interview that's up on YouTube and
Rumble and blazing everywhere else
already and it's interesting because
it's the same question you see I'm
asking the same question it's like good
people good people
the Democrats failed good people so now
good people are getting involved and
they're running as Republicans even if
they maybe weren't traditional
Republicans another one of those people
is Ohio Republican JD Vance and I was
one of the first people to have JD on
again this is this is July of 2021 so
this is even before I had uh Blake on
and the main reason that he was running
is he was seeing how meth and all of
these drugs were getting in and they
were killing the young people of Ohio
and he was not happy about it not a
traditional politician or republican
here here's uh how he feels the left is
treating everyday folks are you
surprised how radical the left has gone
that there is no room for these people
professionally educated people who went
to Ivy League schools who tend to have
pretty radical views about politics
because of it I think a little of it is
definitely economic the left completely
unable to solve America's real problems
is sort of resorted to criticizing most
Americans as backwards or racist in some
way way and so yeah it's really
startling it's really depressing but you
know it is it is where we is and I
unfortunately you know it is what it is
and I think unfortunately we just have
to fight these people
what's super interesting about JD is
that he's thought of as this you know
right-wing Republican Mega Trump
whatever he is actually a disaffected
liberal like me he did not support Trump
in 2016. so he represents this thing
that is happening all across the country
the Liberals turned on liberalism and
they turned the decent liberals uh the
awake as opposed to woke liberals they
turn them into conservatives that's what
they did who else became a star during
all of this well Carrie Lake who I I
think of all of the people is sort of
the real lock out of these guys for
tomorrow she has just become a media
All-Star she is just laying it out with
these nonsensical questions she beats
these people back she stepped away from
a career in journalism she was an actual
journalist she was a mainstream media
journalist and she saw the lies first
hand okay she had the number one show in
Arizona she had tons of money she did
not have have to do it but she got
involved too Carrie Lake welcome to the
Reuben report hi Dave thank you for
having me I'm so excited to be here I'll
probably be the first governor Arizona's
ever seen that truly was in it for the
right reasons to represent the great
people of this state
and she has fought for a border and sane
economic policy and same policies when
it comes to crime and drugs and all of
the other stuff she voted for Obama in
08. I voted for Obama in 08. you get
what we're doing here people here's
another guy certainly not a traditional
Republican actually it was Oprah and you
may remember Oprah Jimmy Kimmel used to
play her in blackface on his man show uh
Oprah put this guy on the map his name
is Dr Oz uh and here he is you may
remember this we played it a couple
weeks ago during the Pennsylvania Senate
debate comparing himself to John
fetterman when it comes to crime and
some of the other radical policies
coming from the Democrats John fetterman
during this crime wave has been trying
to get as many murderers convicted and
sentenced to life in prison out of jail
as possible including people who are
similar to the man who murdered her
husband he does it without the with the
rest of the parole board agreeing he's
doing it without the families on board
these radical positions extend beyond
crime to wanting to legalize all drugs
to open the Border uh to raising our
taxes I want Washington to be civil
again
you need it to be less radical John
Federman unfortunately would bring that
isn't this super interesting you got a
tech guy like Blake Masters right not
thought of as a traditional Republican
you got a guy like JD Vance okay did not
vote for Trump was actively against
Trump in 2016. he got Carrie Lake and
Obama supporter in 08. you got Dr Oz who
was loved by Oprah and now Oprah is
supporting John fetterman these are
media and entertainment people these are
tech people these are not these are not
people that you could pin as like their
Bible thumping Republican conservative
mean not even that any of that is true
but you know what I mean you can't pin
them that way they're people who come
from a little more of a Walk of Life
that like I do which I think many of you
do that were just kind of decent people
and then they decided to get in on this
and you know who also used to be loved
by liberals a guy that used to be on TV
shows all all the time and it was doing
media appearances everywhere and on
every late night show and all of those
things and and donating to Hillary
Clinton and everything else yeah that
guy Donald Trump Donald Trump used to
hang out with all of the very people who
call him a Nazi today well he did a
rally right here in Miami Florida over
the weekend and uh he told the people
who they should vote for people of
Florida are going to re-elect the
wonderful the Great
friend of mine Marco Rubio to the United
States Senate
are you going to re-elect Ron DeSantis
as your governor of your state
love that Applause for DeSantis it's
it's perfect and it's right and it's
good and yes that's exactly what's going
to happen here in the Free State of
Florida and uh Ron DeSantis as I've said
many times it does not say president on
his desk but I think in essence he has
been the de facto president of the
United States the president of the free
United States I should say over the last
two years as Biden and the Democrats
have tried to trample on all of your
freedoms DeSantis led the charge against
it and by Leading the charge against it
he was he signaled to people that you
can be part of a Freedom Movement that's
exactly what I talked to him about in
Orlando in Disney country back in May
when I was on tour
I think people get it more than they
ever have they understand you look at
some of these Elite bureaucrats like
fauci you look at the corporate media
big Tech the emperor has no clothes
these are discredited Elites in our
country and they don't have your best
interests at heart they don't have this
state's best interests at heart
sometimes though it doesn't feel like
you know your voice can be heard because
so much of it is dominated by this one
viewpoint but when you stand up and you
stand in that fire and you fight back
for people man they will have your back
they will support you and that's what
we've shown in the state of Florida
in it true I'm telling you guys it's
true I have had many articles trying to
cancel me I have had people that have
tried to destroy me I I've had all I've
had protesters yelling at me and
throwing things at me and not spilling
coffee on me and blah blah blah I have
been called a Nazi and a bigot and
everything else but I just kept going I
don't know why but I just kept going and
Ron DeSantis he just kept owing a guy
who won by 30
000 votes last time less than one
percent against a guy that turned out to
be a meth addict uh is now going to win
by a is going to absolutely crush it
tomorrow and model that across the
country because he just did the right
thing that really is it but let's
juxtapose the right thing with the not
right thing here's Sonny Hosten on The
View
I read a poll just yesterday that white
Republican Suburban women are now going
to vote Republican why it's almost like
roaches voting for raid right now
honey you think you know
what anyone's interests are but your own
do you know that women man it doesn't
matter parents they've just had it you
people forced parents to feel that they
had to inject their kids with some [ __ ]
that they did not know what it was and
now rates in young men of myocarditis
are through the roof that is happening
for real so please Sunny Hosten do not
pretend you have anyone's interest in
mine other than the dingbats who have
hired you on that ridiculous show so
this is a stark contrast guys
the choice is yours right like the
choice is right now this is the moment
of choosing so let's back up to Tudor
Dixon who is running against against
Gretchen Whitmer and again Gretchen
Whitner Whitmer she has been one of the
worst and uh she really banged up
Whitmer uh uh Tudor banged up Whitmer on
Dan bongino's show uh just yesterday and
now all of those Suburban moms who say
our kids got locked out of school our
kids missed all of their Sports they
missed their Milestone moments of prom
of graduation now they're behind this
woman is the alternative Tudor Dixon is
the alternative to help us get our kids
back on track this is the deplorables
moment of 2016 and that will drive more
people to the polls they won't talk
about it it will be a shock to come
Tuesday she was actually responding
directly to that Sunny hosted moment I
mean this attack this attack on moms who
just want to protect their kids I mean I
can tell you as a new father like that
is my freaking job more than this is my
job I think about it I actually think
about it every morning every single
morning because when I'm doing this when
I'm preparing for the show and I'm
sitting there with Luke and Justin and I
I do an hour with the two of them while
David's doing some other stuff in the
morning and I sit on the couch with two
of them and I've got uh well now I prop
Justin up on the couch I build a little
little castle for him with blankets and
I've got I've got Luke in the docket and
I'm sitting there and I'm going through
the stories of the day and I really am
thinking about how I have to fight
harder for good ideas and for Freedom so
that these kids don't grow up in a world
that is worse and and we have been
heading to a world that is worth so when
Sunny Hosten and the rest of these
people they attack the parents the
parents who didn't want their kids
genitals chopped off their parents who
wanted their kids to go to school who
wanted them not to have masks so that
they could see teachers faces so that
they could mimic the way that they spoke
that's actually how you start speaking
as a child but they're gonna just keep
going and then what are they going to do
and this is going to be the the grandest
of all tricks and these people have
plenty of tricks up their sleeve but
assuming that the Red Wave happens
tomorrow suddenly you know what's going
to happen on Wednesday you're going to
be allowed to talk about election
interference again you're going to be
allowed and encouraged actually to
promote that there was fraud in the
election and everything else much like
say I don't know Stacey Abrams has been
making a career of where Hillary Clinton
did for four years under Trump Etc et
cetera check out this headline from
Politico this is this past weekend the
2020 presidential election was Rife with
allegations of voting machine hacks that
were later debunked yet there are real
risks that hackers could tunnel into
voting equipment and other election
infrastructure to try to undermine
Tuesday's vote man they are seeding the
ground do you get it do you see it I'm
sorry if you see it because it's you're
going oh [ __ ] I don't want to see it
because once I see it I can't unsee it
but you see it right you see it
so Wednesday morning after the red wave
that is what's going to happen and
mainstream media will be running around
with election interference and what
happened to do
ladles and jelly spoons what is the
point of all of this the point is get
out there and vote please vote please
vote encourage the people around you to
vote be part of this system don't let
the Democrat Democrats repeat what they
have done to us end this woke nonsense
now end it now
and as I said last week if it ends and
and I know I don't mean it'll end like
if they'll just wrap it up and be good
to go no will they start questioning
elections again probably will they
unleash violence again probably has so
much of this infected our institutions
that it won't just go away overnight of
course of course of course but
but
if we really start standing for Freedom
if we vote in some people who may some
of them may not be great I think I've
laid out a couple people that I really
think are great obviously it starts with
DeSantis but I think Harry Lake I think
Blake Masters I think there is a chance
of new different Republicans to come in
and Usher in a Resurgence of American
exceptionalism I think it's there but
will many of them fail us they will but
at least we will have had a moment to
say enough of all of this that AOC and
the squad and compromise Biden and the
ideas of socialism and communism and the
rest of it none of this is flying
anymore we are done with it as a country
and we we're not going to arrest you
we're not going to jail you people
whatever
but we're moving on from you and the
culture will move on and Elon owning
Twitter will help it move on and we will
get past it I really really think we can
guys it's me Monday over at the Reuben
report locals Community this is what I
put up this morning I paid Elon 100
grand for my Tesla and now he wants
another eight dollars if you haven't
heard Elon wants eight bucks from
everybody to get a blue check on Twitter
it's one of the ways he's trying to
clean up Twitter and all these
quote-unquote journalists are freaking
out about it uh because they because one
of the reasons that people pay attention
to all these political people and Daily
Beast people and huffpo people is
because they just have the blue check
next to their name because the
organizations worked with Twitter to
verify all of these people who really
had no influence and no following in
anything else and the fact that they're
going to lose that because everyone's
going to be able to get verified soon
meaning confirm that you are who you are
it's just more of that that curtain
being peeled away and instead of the
Great and Powerful eyes it's just some
washed up wizard all right a couple
comments from the locals Community
backup never says I just want some
normal see back we've been in Bizarro
world for too long that's the point
that's the point and we really could do
it we really could do it it's why I've
been saying it for weeks because you
have to know you can do it you have to
make a decision in your mind to live in
reality we are here in Florida we live
in reality all the time I go out and
about and I meet people everywhere
everyone's living in reality here in
Florida but reality now has to burst
forth into the mainstream right reality
got suppressed by the mainstream now
reality has to burst forth and we just
have to you know imagine if it's in 10
years from now and we're like you're
sitting over you're at dinner with some
friends or you're like remember AOC yeah
whatever happened to her I don't know
either do I wouldn't that be great
because it would just be like this blip
there was this very odd blip that we
would all look back remember when
Democrats were always trying to cut kids
genitals off that remember whatever
happened with that
being excited to me before we started
you realize you've said something about
chopping Children's Dental software 15
consecutive shows it's like wouldn't it
be nice to not do that it would be a
pleasure not to talk about children's
genitals being chopped off that is my
goal going forward and I think we're
almost there people
we the free says what about Elder
DeSantis in 2024. let's discuss 2024
after tomorrow look just get out there
and vote EK says if we don't reverse
things with this election do you think
the country is actually over
look if we don't
over I mean over over over
the story of humanity is a never-ending
story so I don't know about over but it
will be much more complicated and much
more painful so I think we got some
chances I think look even though as I
said last week I'm very bullish on
something like 54 in terms of the senate
for Republicans I really am it's like
could fetterman win somehow Oprah and
Bill Clinton were out there with him
this weekend it's like could he win I
suppose he could I'm pretty sure Carrie
lake is going to win in Arizona and
that'll get Blake over the hump over
there as well you know uh uh Georgia
it's like what's going to happen in
Georgia like has the Democrat machine
done enough to harm Marshall Walker and
it's not like he was the greatest
candidate ever he's obviously better
than Raphael Warnock who's a racist a
genuine racist and socialist but it's
like could they lose that one sure
Florida will be strengthened for sure
like there's going you know I really
think the one and I hope I'm right so we
can play the clip over and over I hope
Lee zeldon wins it's like that is the
one and that's like man if New York New
York could turn around and it's happened
before people don't forget George Pataki
was a pretty good Republican governor in
New York two term not too long ago and
it was a total shocker when it happened
in the first place guys if you want to
play along uh join us at
reubenreport.locals.com my full
interview with Michael Shermer who wrote
a new book all about debunking
conspiracy theories it's really
fantastic that's up on locals right now
it'll be up everywhere else soon my full
interview with Tom Cotton is up
everywhere Senator Tom Cotton my full
interview with Tudor Dixon that I just
mentioned uh is up right now across
platforms tomorrow's a big day we've got
a ton to do today we got to prepare we
got to get to Tampa as I said I'm
hosting the DeSantis Victory party we're
going to live stream from there we'll do
a show in the morning much much much
much much much much more
did I breathe during the show there was
not one breath I did not inhale once
anyway guys uh we got a great cold close
for you have a great day get out there
and vote and uh I love America that's
all bye well here is the God's truth
about January 6 2021
close your eyes inflation is near
historic highs now so where do you think
Americans are feeling it the most
this is a huge burden for most families
now paying nearly 450 more a month just
for the basics than they were a year ago
tiger Republicans the extreme right the
the the the trumpies it's now warning
that the US is likely to dip into
recession showing this country has now
reached more than one million coveted
deaths I'm talking about these extreme
maggot Republicans think about it recent
shootings in New York City have
spotlighted a troubling rise in gun
violence and homicide across the country
Ultra Maggie Republicans homicide rates
in Philadelphia continue to grow this
mural actually has the names of those
killed or injured by gun violence over
the years in the city most of those
people are black tell you about this
Ultra Magna agenda
now extreme Mega Republicans and Maggie
republicans in Congress we're back with
the latest on the crisis at the southern
border according to Customs and Border
Protection data a record 2.76 million
migrants cross the border during the
2022 fiscal year shattering the previous
annual record by more than one million
close your eyes close your eyes please
close your eyes
foreign
[Music]